if Patriot Act was for America what Tick  Tock in China is doing is for the world  and if Tick Tock in China has the kind  of data where they can track what's on  your phone you're given a permission  Rogan read this on his podcast and  people were blown away that thing got a  few billion views everybody's sitting  there oh that's right he read the  Privacy read the Privacy report saying  they can look at your finger what  movements you make on your phone Tick  Tock has the right to measure that on  your phone on other apps you're logging  on to it's tick tock is Patriot Act on  steroids and if Apple drops Twitter off  their app it has to do with Tick Tock it  has to do with Channel